okay well we all know gas prices are
incredibly high we are keeping up our
campaign with the folks from conoco and
it was my turn to surprise a conoco
customer and gift him a good day
i met justin at the conoco station on
rainbow down mountains edge he moved
here from texas his gas prices are
hitting him in the pocket real hard oh
gas is in outrageous actually uh what
was the most that you've paid or is this
the most i've paid
i think was a little bit more into
closer into town and it was i believe
5.74
ouch he was unempty told me he needed to
fill a 22 gallon tank
that's when we gave him a big surprise i
don't know if you know this but today is
turning out to be a pretty good day for
you we want to gift you
enough money to hopefully pay for your
gas we got my assistant over here you
just won some gas money justin thank you
oh my goodness we are gifting you a good
day thank you
holy moly
is this gonna make your day it will it
really will oh my goodness this is gonna
i mean it's gonna help me get through
the week this is it this is the next you
know week and a half of driving thank
you guys so much thank you 8 news now
thank you conoco it is insane i've never
thought about this ever happening in my
life
so cool for justin and the team there we
had a great time with
jen and marcel and john you could be
next we want you to keep an eye out for
all of us going to have another gifting
a good day coming up on monday now we
want to check the forecast sherry